he is Washington [ __ ] cornerback Josh
Norman how you doing Josh hey hey guys
doing we're fine we're if we found you
where we found you where are you see
thank you
where are you we're always that we
always know where to find ya where are
you you just buy like a coffee or
something weird we can no no no right
here uh training okay this the soccer
team the past tense of man club out here
in Miami and shoot the guys encounters
but it was a deal for me I was like hi
hold on I'll come out in a second so
okay so yeah you're working out with a
soccer team right now yeah I was out
here working out with the Emma Brennan
building that wind up that endurance
these guys Melda level but it's cool to
kind of get out here and switch it up a
little bit try something new and see
what we can implement in our game
so you're saying footballers as they're
known around the globe are potentially
better conditioned as athletes than
American football players John Schneider
yeah oh yeah I would say so I would say
so justice in fact of these guys even
all day two hours straight non-stop sin
it's like that's true keeping up with
the pack you know they got a little the
week bird in the back just scribbling to
keep up but then you know he got that
heart is beating it ain't being kool-aid
and can catch up to those guys and try
to hold it as best we can but this
immunity is another level right here so
I see why they come out here and train
so you're spending your last remaining
days before you you go to training camp
in South Florida working out is that
what what are you doing over the next
couple days before you have to report to
Redskins park Josh well I'll be working
out here um Chinese guys and I got a
press China talking about his way are we
working out alongside the team and
getting involved a little bit activities
and they teach me a thing or two and you
know vice versa I think you can learn
from different sports it's you always
want to work on your craft and seeing
what you can get better in she's just
thinking it's just football America is
this different because me being a
cornerback and I'll always work on my
feet and
and still a nota - from from Cavani
ordeal Maria someone like that you know
our gang out of this is out here can
show me a thing - [ __ ] I could probably
take it back and use it on the frost
area that we play on okay Josh Norman
the Washington Redskins joining me here
on the show Matt may I run through a few
recent to us days headlines with you
Josh Norman and get your two cents on
these subjects that okay but I'm pretty
sure Rick you always love to do that
hold on a minute no no big you you
you're always ill you always have an
interesting take that's why one of the
many reasons I love chatting with you
and you never be asked me Josh Norman
you never do that and will never I never
on BS you AR okay I know why would I do
such a thing why I know because we're
tight luck I know man that you set your
people free and this means that you talk
too much of the truth then people have a
notion to call you out for things that
you know why did you I live I live in a
fact-based world Josh you know what I'm
exactly and there's a lot of fantasy
people out there living in fairytale
land and it's just like oh wow oh gosh
mm-hmm all right so let's start off if
you don't mind in your former place of
business in Carolina which of let go
Dave gentlemen the general manager we
noticed your Twitter account with a
couple of emojis brockton what were the
emojis DeeDee look at this yeah yeah he
had the eyes and then the face and then
and then a retweet of of Stephen a going
off about how gentleman handled your
contract negotiations so what our if you
could put in your own words your
thoughts on Gettleman firing in Carolina
I mean I don't really have much at all
in you know it's just thinking of if
you're that high level level why would
you think of such a thing to do she's
know of shooting you go back from a
Super Bowl contender team tonight and
you wonder why you look around and you
know I didn't just you know bring that
that fire on the field
we brought a different element of
chemistry in the locker where they
brought you know guys together and shoot
little sticky Steve over there and it's
just you know take one of those places
people in those parts out since you know
you don't subscribe to those type of
players what you think is going to
happen in a way like meaning face those
dogs an NFC South over there
you know when they went up against those
wide receivers I do that guys included
that I don't see why he wouldn't you
know person in that position should
obviously already have that in mind but
like I said I wouldn't Draft by the guy
so obviously he probably don't know you
know my story hi I came from up from
that part of the team too you know
rising the rink so where I'm at today
which is Wow but I don't know I don't
like kick nobody on it down I'm not that
guy I know that you Josh no I know that
and then also you know obviously if
you're in a spot where you're happy so
you don't want to get your land yeah I
know you don't want to come it across
like you know what you're you're you're
unhappy being in a spot where you you
are to talk about the spot that you were
in but when Steven a you but you
retweeted what Steven a said is that an
accurate portrayal as to what happened
was you and gentlemen that's there its
FETs there like it's not it's not it's
not no you know it's taking a case I
mean he spoke some facts that I actually
you know it was real and it was truthful
and I was just like okay well actually
that kind of did happen so in all things
not it happened it was just sent back
here looking at like man at the end of
the day you have guys in that higher
position you would think the
decision-making would not be rational it
would be thought out and planned it
didn't it wasn't like son of a gun I had
to make it that day you know could have
waited man like the gelada 15th date was
coming up in time soon you know it was
just so rational and just stupidity on
at that level but like I said I'm not
the guy that's up there making those
decisions today you know like I said I
like kick my body lay down but if I was
walked by someone and I just you know he
was down in the ground I just tripped or
something and my foot came up I mean I
don't think I would apologize for it but
that's just kind of happened
Josh Norman here on the Rich Eisen show
what do you what do you make of what has
gone down between your current
quarterback and the front office with
Kirk Cousins leg and y-yeah I don't
think I take nothing knee or make
nothing of it
you know he's our quarterback he's with
Washington Redskins he's the quarterback
for our team and other franchise in
faith he's gonna lead us into battle and
we're gonna sound battledrums and we'll
go out there and fight we don't win and
nothing more needs to be taken out of it
as you see all the time hearing these
things on these questions acts like
people what is it like really and I'm
not talking about Qi rich I'm just
talking about in general you know you
think those questions actually get those
things that goes around all the time I
do he is here with us right now he is on
another franchise tag he is okay like
people like let's get real he is okay
and when we do suddenly decide to do
something that's on geminate front
office you know there's a lot of people
know it's crazy that we try to run the
team from a fan or fan bases standpoint
then just go out there and see what the
team does yes we have passionate fans
and they very emotional but the front
office's is at the front office if you
was in the front office or you not your
family to a reason if you're in front
office you there for a reason
so I mean the route for teams awesome
and great to continue you know bash the
team that you root for and the way we do
is kind of like wow that's crazy you
know but at the same time we got passing
fans and I look tough and I ain't
nothing but HTT are run through these
things
I can't wait to shoot my arrows off and
go ham that's right now in terms of that
Josh Norma a couple more headlines to
run by you here dak Prescott says that
the Cowboys will win the NFC East Landon
Collins today from the Giants saying I
highly doubt that they don't control the
East I give you the floor sir well I
don't think here is a floor to take you
know I think we should wrap up on our
you know buckle them change straps put a
helmet on you know kind of pass with
just a little bit tighter than normal
and we're gonna dig our crease down in
that grass looking god did
I just tell them get past me and we'll
see what happens
no for quarters up we'll see who runs
victorious man I think that's that's
when you can say all this stuff because
it's early right now to say it is easy
it comes out to novel right slick it
sounds good mm-hmm but like I said when
you scrap up you're getting twin on
white lines look a man in his eye four
quarters in you'll see what who comes
out victorious and that was announced
the most okay and that guy when you do
it with Dallas is going to be Dez right
because you're going to travel with Dez
every single one right right I don't
know man that's that's up to the coach
okay well done see I'm just front-loaded
I front-loaded the weak one a week to
storyline on you right now here in July
Joe I'm getting you ready for the season
I'm getting you ready for the season
with the paparazzi that's how I'm doing
trust me man I'm freaking ant that has
to funk those guys in person believe it
always do man is always fun football
around the collective and in terms of
that with the bow and arrow what are
your thoughts on the new relaxed
celebration policies with that headline
in the National Football League Josh
Norman well I think the fans hopefully
you know hopefully the league continue
to listen to the fans and hear what they
want because obviously that's stir they
want they move towards you know you know
we we should give a long way to go
though but still you know they got
something out of the way that I feel
like a sense once seeing you want to
take on and enjoy because you got think
about of those kids they're going to be
doing it when they go back you know
they're old school and they probably Six
Flags are fine but not fines with flags
until they get up to the bigs and in a
way we just having fun and I think it's
a relaxed day you got to have fun this
game to be successful I feel if you
don't you're going to suck so I have as
much fun as I can and I embrace it I
celebrate with the fans and my teammates
I just want to win man have a good time
I don't feel like you know everybody
should be clean a disappointed
battlefield this guys RuPt if he don't
care about this or the that's not the
case I just want to have fun and give
something back to the fans who pay they
hard on money to being on seats you know
that's where we are right Josh Norman
you just got me fired up I'm gonna go
run through a brick wall right now
because football is right around I'm so
doing coming in by coming in by 3:00
a.m. running on the beach for our man
you can get it in oh and we had that so
many motivation okay I'm looking forward
to a Josh thanks for the call be safe
enjoy your workouts in South Florida and
we'll chat with you down the line okay
sound like a plan most appreciate their
beto as always that's Josh Norman the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy